I think I always had two dreams one was
to be a filmmaker and one was to work
with Martin Scorsese the wolf of Wall
Street you never think you're gonna get
that kind of opportunity to work with
your favorite director and how insanely
good leo is and how wonderful was to
watch him and watch him work and you go
ordered all the [ __ ] sites tell them
about the side the side side $26,000
worth besides one of these signs that
kill cancer decides to cure cancer
that's the problem they weren't there
that's why they were expensive shut the
[ __ ] up I'm serious I know Bob it was
just the best until making mid-90s
it was the formative experience in my
life because every day for like six
months I get to watch Martin Scorsese
she seems she solve problems come up
with ideas on the spot and it was just
such an incredible education
it was great he's also the best he also
has the best laughs he's funny he's I
missed him a lot after it ended because
I just like loved seeing him every day I
learned so much from him and that was
the best best acting experience I ever
had for sure it's one of those ones that
the experience matched what people liked
about the movie you know I just remember
I always tried to make my gold break
like laughs like is a [ __ ]
you know I'm seriously getting [ __ ]
sick of you talking about her like that
frankly if we can be honest with each
other we do like why do you hate her so
much you've never given me a reason I'm
starting to just think that you like her
[ __ ] no man I hate that never I can
never break him he's so good like I
could just never get him to laugh in a
scene and then one time I just sneezed
and he started like cracking up I was so
frustrated that that's what got him to
laugh like something I didn't even mean
to do and it was just funny that that's
what made him laugh I was trying for
like two months to make him laugh in the
scene
and then a sneeze is all it took
Superbad was a great experience and what
it mainly did besides just being very
fun in a movie I'm proud of it
it was an incredible like opportunity to
get a seed planted in me by Greg and
Seth and Evan basically of like you can
make a film that's exactly your voice
and your ethic and your Sensibility for
me it was really important to see that
at a young age because these people were
making something that really was exactly
in their style and it was so epic to
just watch and then later on you know
that seed grew into like wow what could
the thing that I want to make is you
know 21 Jump Street I wrote the story
for 21 Jump Street and created the
characters and with my friend Michael
Bacall and I started working on that
when I was 23 and then we shot it when I
think I was 27 maybe 20 26 and it was
great the the the best part I think was
watching it kind of turn from everybody
was so didn't understand why we wanted
to do it and they didn't get the idea of
making fun of remaking a TV show and how
lazy and like that's how Hollywood is
and now I've seen that done a lot since
in comedies where they're like so self
referential and aware of like like
winking at the camera almost in that way
and I do think that was a novel idea of
like the characters in the film being
aware we're reviving a canceled
undercover police program from the 80s
and revamping it for modern times you
see the guys in charge of this stuff
lack creativity and are completely out
of ideas so all they do now is recycle
[ __ ] from the past and expect us all not
to notice that
they're in a lazy dumb big Hollywood
idea is it was was something I was
really into and then it was amazing
because we were trying to find who's
gonna play the other person
Channing Tatum at that time was like
known for like romantic like romantic
movies and stuff he was in like he was
in step up and he was in a Nicholas
Sparks thing so he was a successful
actor my pitch to him because no one
wanted to do it and so I was like look
women really like you but guys think
you're like you know like a dancer or
like a romance person you know he's like
I think if you do this movie you'll
become like this giant movie star
because everyone will be a fan of yours
because he was so funny when I met him I
was like whoa and it ended up being this
great partnership friendship he's
someone who I really like love and
respect and and also Phil Lord and Chris
Miller who were so talented I hired them
off of Cloudy with a Chance of Meatballs
and they hadn't even shot a frame of
live-action film and now they're these
you know big directors and it's it's
it's cool to watch those films from back
then or see what everyone's up to from
when you were younger to see how their
careers blossom and and how they sort of
like grow Cyrus I love Marc and Jade
applause I think they're amazing they
had written a script for Cyrus and
honestly it was like one of the best
scripts I've ever read and that in
Superbad stand out to me as the two best
screenplays I've ever read where I was
like you could see the whole movie so
well and I just thought it was such a
unique character I loved their film the
puffy chair and I got to work with john
c reilly and Marissa Tomei and it was I
was like 23 or 24 and it was it was such
a great experience I loved their script
but then they wanted us to improvise but
I thought the script was so wonderful
that I kind of wanted to stick to it but
then they they liked improvisation
they're just insane dude and the funny
thing about that movie is
mark was an actor at that time and Jay
was just behind the camera and I was
like if I ever make a movie I'm gonna
put Jay in it because he's such an
interesting guy and it's the way toxa
know he is and then Jay became a famous
actor on transparent and so I didn't put
him in the mood in my movie because I
was like our Jill Soloway I already got
him first but I was like he had no
ambition of being an actor you know so
it was interesting to watch him just
like now with Jays like a famous actor
it's funny you know it's great
the whole set was lit so you could
literally walk into another room in the
middle of your performance and they
could follow you
it just was so free and fluid there on
Steadicam so you know it was handheld so
they could like follow you you had
complete freedom as an actor and I had
never really seen that before
[Music]
what
sorry I was in the neighborhood and
Cyrus came out to let me in i'm sorry i
love john c reilly I think he's I don't
know I've worked with a lot of great
actors and he's definitely like top
three or I don't know maybe number one
he's so brilliant this is the end I just
like think Seth and Evan are geniuses
and they have they're such their own
unique style and voice and they were
gonna direct their first movie and of
course I was gonna want to be in their
first movie you know and they had
written everybody as at versions of
themselves and my only contribution was
my character I was like he should be
really really nice but it should be like
false thank you that was really fun I
had never gotten to work with Danny
McBride I think Danny McBride is like
the funniest person in the world I think
he's bounding down is the most batshit
wonderful show and I just think he's a
huge talent he was my neighbor actually
yeah Danny we lived across the street
from you at one point and that was cool
I love I love him poor dog war dogs was
a crazy shoot it was shot in Morocco Las
Vegas Los Angeles El Centro Miami Oh
Romania yeah
Romania Morocco El Centro Los Angeles
Miami Las Vegas it was like that much
movement with the whole film crew is
chaos
so like Todd is a really good director
and really smart but it was like it was
a hard shoot because of all the travel
and all the different countries and
adjusting a new crew in each country but
I just thought this story once I read
that article I was like I remember just
reading the article in Rolling Stone was
like this would make an incredible movie
so and I'd been a fan of Todd's for a
long time so it was kind of a no-brainer
I grew up skateboarding in Los Angeles
I worked a shop called hot rod I used to
go to the courthouse every day it was
just it was a great time so for me
skateboarding really you know what it
did was it kind of like connected me to
an ethic and a point of view and an anti
ethic it really gave me a really solid
group of friends and at a time when it's
you and your friends against the world
and I always thought it's um in some way
skateboarding and that kind of
experience in point of view would be a
part of my first film but then I didn't
realize it'd be ending up like the
complete just let say the backdrop you
know it's not like a skateboarding movie
it's just that's who these people are
people just understand when you're the
young kid and you're moving your way up
through the animal kingdom and in trying
to find your place amongst a group of
people and find out how to belong and
have such a special experience you think
you're pretty cool to ghetto-ass friends
you good
you think you're tough and [ __ ] gives us
some little [ __ ] kid
a lot of the time we feel like our lives
are the worst
but think of you looking anybody else's
closet you may trade your ship for their
[ __ ] so let's go that's why we ride up
he's some food like what that best to
some mutton spear the kids in the film
are amazing watching them become great
actors and their skaters from you know
that weren't actors like there's nothing
more exciting than that this was an
amazing first experience as a filmmaker
because it now gives me courage to go on
and go deeper and more meaningful and
you know I think if I had done it any
earlier I would have hit the brakes in
certain parts in a way that would have
made the movie worse my whole dream my
whole life was to be a filmmaker and I
got this incredible film school for the
last 15 years and had this have this
great you know lucky careers and after
where you get to watch all these
different kinds of directors work you
know and I got to watch pretty much all
of my heroes make film you know I'm very
lucky in that way but I really wanted to
wait until I felt I had gained enough
knowledge and enough I would say courage
to tell a story that really meant
something